hot breath in this case what i'm doing
is i'm taking an element and comparing
it to my wife
rather than finding traits about my wife
and then finding the element to relate
it to
like if i my ex-wife was a alcoholic
right
so i said uh so i you i played on that
angle
i said what else is alcoholic what else
is alcoholic funny cars
funny cars are alcohol fueled so if i
say my want my ex-wife yeah my ex-wife
she's alcohol she's like a funny car
alcohol-fueled now i have a quick joke
there but i'm working the other approach
to it
the alternate approach finding what is
she like
and then finding something to relate her
to this way i'm taking any element and
comparing it to my ex-wife
and then listing everything i can think
about
using uh subcategories of people places
things words phrases cliches
events and and i'll write that down
people places things words phrases
cliches events every single time i do a
list
to remind myself because when you're so
close to it you're going through the
list sometimes you just get
too heady and i'll go oh i didn't do any
cliches here what do people say when
they say this what people
are involved in smartphone can you hear
me now that guy you know and i'll just
write down everything i can about a
smartphone what else in smartphone in
the minutia
the signal what about the signal the
bars hey what are some of the phrases
hey my phone's only had two bars bars
bars double entendre that's a bar could
be a drinking establishment
fits for my ex-wife now because my
ex-wife's like a smartphone you know
at any given time i can usually find her
at least one bar
same phrase fits for a phone breath